I really don't do much Twitter man the
only thing on Twitter what the hell is
that
bro just watch this
hi impressive carrying skills right I
got some Bud Lights for us so I kept
hearing about this thing called March
Madness and I thought we were all just
having a hectic month but it turns out
it has something to do with sports and
I'm not sure exactly which sport but
either way it's a cause to celebrate
this month I celebrated my day three why
do I say like something in the neck like
there's like a lump there's a lump in
the neck yeah I don't know what what
would that be bro you would know better
than I would was that supposed to mean
dog I'm fat G I could barely see my neck
how are you gonna think I could know
better than you bro you just know better
than I do
what is that thing though that is that
is interesting that's definitely uh 65 a
woman and Bud Light Sent Me possibly the
best gift ever a can with my face on it
check out my Instagram story to see how
you can enjoy March Madness with Bud
Light and maybe win some money too love
ya bro let me actually put this on
Twitter real quick how crazy is it that
I literally can't get any brand deals at
all because I watch Tate Cheers Cheers
whatever team you love
in what world does hiring this person to
promote your brand make any sense like
what Bud Light drinkers support this
garbage and it's gonna make them more
money I'll tell you what I heard Bud
Light uh stocks kind of crashed and I
feel like maybe uh Coors Light is the
way to go right now so I'm gonna buy
some Coors Light stocks and uh we're
gonna go up dude wait that's Haram isn't
it alcohol yeah that's harambro come on
all right I don't even drink alcohol so
I think I'm okay but it's crazy to me
like it's it's so obvious that's this
whole agenda isn't just about money like
everyone's saying like oh the reason
that they stay woke is for money and
it's like it's not even true like most
people are waking up right now so the
fact that they're still promoting this
garbage shows that it's something about
emasculating and I mean I'm feminizing
men compared to just oh we want to make
more money like who's buying Bud Light
because of this garbage definitely not
me dude and not an even drink it's
definitely not going to want to make me
drink I'll tell you what there's a
certain word that starts with the letter
d and ends with the the sound shun and
uh if your IQ is high enough to kind of
put that word together you know you'll
kind of uh you'll catch on to to what it
is bro I forgot they haven't seen the
video where I'm bald bro oh my God yeah
I guess a lot of them don't know oh snap
I didn't even know how I went ball from
the first video I have a lisp you got
this do I have this it's got me so oh
yeah I guess they haven't even seen you
go bald yet either yeah I know yeah
that's so funny yeah what can I say man
let's just say you guys are hopefully
gonna find out what the [__] was that I
got a baddie for you yeah I don't know
[__] buddy
[Music]
but these are the same people that are
literally ending up at the White House
to to you know create good attention for
them but in reality it's like dude this
is not the look we should be having as
America me personally speaking
[Applause]
who the hell even has a a stack of beers
like that in their shower dude unless
they're like living in Alabama or
something bro this [__] is just
getting all the brand deals right now
this this garbage
this is tens of thousands of dollars of
marketing right here
we thank you for your patience
sorry are you
that's such a [__] yeah dude if I was a
company dog I'd be like bro I'm paying
you for this dude
Miracle yeah no Dylan also had let me
see
a [__] what's it called I think you
spelled Dylan wrong my friend oh [__]
Dylan moganey
look at this [__] too
I don't know bro like I don't want to be
like like a hater but it's like
it's just creepy bro like what is this
bro
um like why is this shoved down our
throat so hard I just don't [__] get
it man I wish this was Rumble dude I'd
go [__] ham
yeah this [__] dude I wish this was
Rumble I know the fact that we can't
even really speak our minds I mean I
could bro when I'm on YouTube dude I
don't give a [__] I'll say anything and
everything and truth be told there is a
lot I could say man there's a lot I can
say I don't really give a [__] I
actually don't think he knows but I'm
actually uh trans myself I'm actually a
female yeah no I'm gonna become
transgender so that I can uh get some
brand deals I took I took hormones and
that's why I have male breasts while
female breasts um so these are my people
you know and because the fact that
they're my people it kind of disappoints
me a little bit bro what the Bro all
right dude I want to challenge this
person to a dance off bro
can we show them how I dance compared to
this dude look at those arms dude it's
like a [__] orangutan
it's like orangutan arms dude look at
that [__] bro how does this make sense
I've never seen a female with arms like
that
[Laughter]
bro I just like look it's like lagging
this is like straight this was NPC dance
move I've ever seen
there's like jumping jacks is now a
dance move dude what yo guys go to the
club if you're if you're not sure how
you can dance to really uh improve the
ladies and peacock dog just start
jumping doing jumping jacks dude I'm
telling you it'll definitely bring in
the attraction oh my God bro when you
were in high school did they have a lot
of this garbage yet or it was still
normal no life was normal dude what so
when did this start after Obama yeah or
during Obama uh I would definitely say
it's in the Obama presidency after that
I think honestly man ever since the
Obama
and everything started to de-escalate in
America
um you know I think just got weird man
everybody's like vote Obama he's black
and then you're like you look at you
like all right you know you give the guy
a chance and then how the F how the [__]
do you get a Nobel Prize just becoming
the president did you get a Nobel Prize
because you're the first black president
or is it just all scripted fetchy keeps
it the [__] real damn I mean there's so
much more I could say dude but I'ma just
I'm gonna let it warm up and then maybe
the people can see us another time
oh my God
I don't know
[Music]
nothing